a lot going on in your life right now I
just want to first of all say thank you
for taking the time out of your schedule
to speak with us how are you doing I'm
doing okay you know obviously I'm not
gonna sit here and say oh I'm amazing
uh that's something I'm kind of shying
away from I'm so used to put the happy
face on I think that's what happens when
you've been on TV for 10 years is you
just learn to be good all the time and I
think that's where my podcast comes into
play is it's okay to not be okay and
that's kind of the place that I'm at
right now is just using my podcast as an
outlet to be vulnerable talk about
everything going on in my life so that
at the end of the day the truth always
comes out and to just kind of be patient
with myself you have a smile on your
face so definitely that makes me happy
how's your family doing they're pushing
through we're at a place where if we put
our faith in God we definitely don't put
our faith in the system so I've never
seen two people my parents be so sad
judge fast in their faith and in prayer
and just literally on their knees every
morning praying and having their time
and to me it's just so admirable and I
that's kind of just my focus is just
watching them and still learning and
growing from them and I'm like this and
just kind of staying strong through it
all and knowing that in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have to I want to
congratulate you on the release of your
Podcast Unlocked so welcome to unlocked
with me Savannah Chrisley there's so
much growth that happens and the
uncomfortable conversations in places to
wear you just never thought growth was
possible I'm curious about the timing
about why you chose now to come out with
this podcast I've always wanted to do a
podcast I just never really made it a
priority I just got to a point where I
was like all right I need an outlet for
myself like my mental health is more
important than all these other projects
that I have going on and I need an
outlet to voice how I'm feeling and
chances are if I'm feeling this way so
many other people are feeling the exact
same way so I want to take what I'm
going through and hopefully make a
difference in even just one person's
life because then for me it wasn't
wasted with our show it was always so
funny and it wasn't we never really hit
deep on much and so I feel like
throughout all the years I had all these
things bottled up that I never got to
speak about and even you know when it
comes to relationships that I spoke
about an NBA player that I did stated
that is just a hot mess you know it's I
was always the bad guy I never got to
tell my truth or what people did to me
and now it's like okay this is the truth
it's not to bash anyone it's just the
truth is anything off limits with this
podcast not at all I think that was kind
of the whole reason I started this was
because I was like there are no
parameters the huge through line and
theme that I found in listening to a few
episodes of unlock is mental health you
talk about it so openly and you share so
much about your personal struggles and
specifically I want to talk about one a
moment that you mentioned that really
kind of hit me in the gut these past few
months have taken on my mental health
have been insane for a lack of a better
term I mean I was not leaving my house I
was not going out and having fun I
kind of was like a robot yes I've there
have been times where I've turned to
alcohol what was it that put you in such
a dark place obviously this whole legal
battle that's been spread across the
news I have had to deal with it from a
child's perspective and have just the
hateful comments on social media and
people just having no Grace or
understanding or really educating
themselves was just so hard to see all
the negativity when I know the people
that are in my life and I know their
hearts and I know the things they are
and are not capable of it was just
really really difficult and two to not
be able to State Our Truth and I think I
just got to a really really low point
and I speak about this in my podcast
about you know suicide and my own
struggles with it I just want to check
on you how are you doing right now how
are things honestly I'm I'm a pretty
strong long individual I'm going to
therapy right after this I am just
making that a priority there's just
things in your life that you need to
make a priority and when you notice that
you're not okay then you have hopefully
the tools to fix it
[Music]